hey can I do you for a moment side okay
I just really need to tell you something
Kelly what do you want to do today I'll
tell my name Casey no Christina no
Candice no Kelsey ay no Sarah this place
is amazing
anything for you who are you oh this is
a group date hi I'm mentally unstable
but I'll find a way to manipulate Chad
into thinking I'm totally normal and
I've already been on two dates with him
so he'll probably break up with me
tonight I haven't seen my kids in 8
weeks just feel like he doesn't even
listen to me anymore yeah my need all of
that again but like a little more
concise and if we can get some
hysterical crying
I'd be fantastic did you get your drink
before this scene Andrew Andrew did she
get the champagne do you want to go back
to the fantasy suite
and this is sweet sex I'm talking about
sex Danny I know we haven't known each
other for very long but will you marry
me no I've known you for eight weeks
you always are bringing around other
women and you're always trying to get me
drunk